in ethiopia's north antigua region nine
months of war between the ethiopian
federal government and leaders in tigrai
has spread into the neighboring regions
of afar and amhara creating a severe
humanitarian crisis
the united nations warns that what's
effectively a blockade on aid convoys by
rebel forces is pushing millions of
people to the brink of farming people
like sadia ali and her five children
they fled their farm two months ago
following an attack by tigray fighters
this makeshift tent in the afa region
has now become their new home she says
it took two weeks to get here by foot
[Music]
the whole journey was through the
scorching sun
and the thirst for drinking water was
agonizing we were forced to drink rain
water from the ground but that made us
sick
last week the wfp called on all parties
to allow the movement of aid into the
region where 90 percent of the
population are in urgent need of help
it estimates 100 trucks of aid need to
intertegre each day to feed them
that warning came as rebel forces
reportedly looted warehouses destroying
crucial food supplies we don't have any
food stocks at the moment to plan with
or to distribute whatever we have is
currently
being distributed or has already been
distributed so what we're looking at
going forward is is a difficult
situation
for us to keep providing services for
our communities here
in our
the number of displaced people facing
farming is expected to rise the
situation
improves unless the fighting dies down
we can only see the situation
deteriorating extensively in the next
weeks and months
a stock warning in a country that's
already suffered so much mohammed
al-jazeera nairobi kenya